as of today there are 15 15 republican
candidates running for president 14 more
could announce in the coming weeks
including Jeb Bush and Scott Walker that
is 29 potential Republican candidates
it's crazy hey Conan yeah what is it I
just got a summons to be a Republican
candidate
you gotta help me get this straight you
gotta know it
[Applause]
let me get this straight you got there
seem happy about it but you got a
summons to be a Republican candidate
yeah it's like jury duty you get called
up you gotta do it yeah but I'm just
curious why you please look at me
I'm a white middle-aged man who grew up
in the Midwest I meet ya there Ali look
I need to go downtown right now and get
a deferral or otherwise they're gonna
start campaigning for me what way do I
can't you just do that after the show
no I have to do it right away or else
they're gonna here we go America needs a
man like Andy Richter for president he
won't just tell you what you want to
hear I don't even like politics and he's
no Washington insider I've only voted a
couple times in my life say he's just
like you and me turn a performer the
legacy of Ronald Reagan I smoke weed I
smoked a ton of weed
he supports America's small farmers
I don't want to run goddamn it and he
believes in God okay look I shot a
drifter and I buried him in my backyard
what do you do with that
he's pro-gun
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]